This is how we’re getting to the moon.
NASA’s SLS lifts the Orion spacecraft carrying
astronauts.
Orion meets up with a lunar variant of Starship
in lunar orbit.
The crew transfers to Starship, which takes
them to the moon's surface.
For the trip home, Starship lifts off, meets
up with Orion, which was left in lunar orbit,
the crew transfers over to Orion, and returns
to Earth.
But what if…Starship was used to go all
the way from earth to the moon?
Starship could launch, meet up with another
Starship to refuel, before journeying to the
moon.
This version of Starship is not the lunar
variant.
It requires the heat shield and flaps for
landing back on earth.